screen junkies asked an actual doctor to
analyze action movies and tell us what
would really happen to your favorite
action years today's patient John
McClane
hip contusion with possible pelvic
fracture concussion with possible skull
fracture and epidural hematoma shoulder
fracture dislocation posterior rib
fractures
testicular hematoma and broken fingers
john mccain is dead we reported
impending chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease third-degree burns tympanic
membrane rupture and scorched airway
John McClane is dead blasts foreign
bodies that probable flexor tendon
lacerations orbital blowout fracture
Manimal fracture zygomatic arch fracture
orbital fracture with no rupture
concussion fractured Larenz John flame
is dead
ballistic shoulder fracture if possible
collapsed on dislocated shoulder both of
the lacerations and blasts foreign
bodies
survival likely good call John McClane
game over
final report John McClane requires four
lives to complete die hard gotta fight
it to the Christmas party by mistake who
knew what movie would you like to see us
analyze next tell us in the comments
below and we'll waste a professionals
time to find out and as always please
subscribe